eu estava fazendo assim pra ver se vocês
batiam palmas
acho que é bastante com o time passou e
pense um cara que faz muita coisa ao
mesmo tempo é bem pequeno pessoal a
criança que não conseguia ficar quieta
mas que tinha um faniquito no rabo
nunca parou na vida sabe com a frase que
eu mais escutei escuto em toda a minha
vida
haroldo de 60 sempre foi assim
hoje eu escutei isso eu escutei isso
ontem haroldo que acarreta direto
prestando visando incluído o cacoete eu
nasci na avenida duque de caxias no
centro de fortaleza em frente ao de nox
muito carro muito ônibus nada de árvore
muita gente passando eu ia de casa para
o colégio e do colégio para casa eu só
conseguia fazer esse caminho
adorava minha casa mas eu fugi da minha
casa para o colégio
eu adorava o colégio mas eu fugi do
colégio na minha casa a minha casa não
era um lugar ruim não era um gatinho
muitos livros e muitos discos três mil
livros e podia consultar o livro que eu
quisesse e abandonar a leitura qualquer
momento poderia ouvir qualquer disco mas
eu podia interromper a audição quando
quisesse
os meus pais nunca reclamaram disso eles
só queriam que eu colocasse um livro e
do disco no mesmo lugar no colégio assim
que eu cheguei
aquele lugar lindo eu fugi da sala de
aula e quando alguém conseguir me
capturar vou fazer de tudo para fugir de
novo na hora do recreio e fugir para
dentro da sala de aula
o banheiro masculino não era
interessante agora o feminino e eu não
tinha certeza ainda meninas ainda não
depois foi né eu não conseguia parar
quieto e nem separar compreende tá eu
tive a sorte de ser o primeiro menino
aprender a ler mas ainda assim era visto
como diferente
o esquisito uma vez eu fui pro colégio
sozinho para receber a medalha de melhor
aluno porque tinha tirado as melhores
notas
mas a mãe já não foi comigo eles
confirmassem fim fui lá não recebi isso
aconteceu há alguns anos seguidos pra
falar a verdade nunca recebeu uma
medalha
apesar de estar tendo essa alegria
maravilhosa está no texas
eu venci o jogo virou mas eu nunca
recebi uma medalha por êxito é técnico
preso estudantil e aí eu comecei a ver
tem alguma coisa errada comigo mas para
minha mãe não tinha para os meus pais
nunca ouvi o meu pai ter muito orgulho
de dizer que eu li de tudo a toda hora
ele fala isso como falar isso com muita
alegria e olhassem para ele vale o
besteirol a mãe dizer que eu era super
inteligente é o meu acreditava nem
duvidava
mas era o que ela vive dizendo que a
gente vai crescendo
começa a ouvir vozes outras que não são
os nossos pais foi ficando adolescente
com 16 anos eu ganhei um festival de
rock no ceará no brasil para quem não
sabe o ceará no nordeste do brasil é um
pólo exportador de chifre de humoristas
e eu sou um desses motoristas ou atores
comediantes desta terra tão maravilhosa
com 16 anos é um festival muito
importante num shopping em fortaleza que
revelou outros tantos rumores ao lado de
edmilson filho que pra quem não sabe é
um outro ator comediante de fortaleza
estava comigo no colégio
no outro ano eu me tornei presidente do
grêmio ingressando no movimento
estudantil
eu fazia parte também da seleção de
vôlei giba
de futebol de salão sendo reserva nas
três eu participar de feiras de ciências
eu participei de todas as competições de
poesia deixei com uma poesia no chão
para o professor vice ele igual que
lindo não ganhei o concurso mas eu tava
lá na poesia tudo eu participei não
conseguir inscrever no concurso de
rainha do colégio não rolou
mas de tudo eu participei continue com a
boa performance estudantil até que
chegou um determinado momento está no
filme ai que lindo que tem que ser dito
né
até que chegou o momento tá bom mulher
até que chegou um momento em que eu
resolvi fazer o vestibular
e aí vai pense um cara que queria fazer
engenharia e arquitetura direito
gastronomia teatro tudo tudo tudo queria
vender jornal tudo eu queria fazer e
resolvi fazer direito e história e fiz
duas faculdades ao mesmo tempo no curso
de história eu era chamado de playboy e
no curso de direito era chamado de
comunista
eu andava com a calça rasgada e brinco e
colarzinho de maconheiro
não que eu fumasse maconha mas é
possível que eu tenha fumado
háháhá
aqui tudo que a gente faz você rir nota
não é né
é muito vocês vocês são muito ligados
cara é muito completo
enfim o homem dividido fazendo muitas
coisas ao mesmo tempo e aí comecei a
aprender a tocar violão porque digamos
que eu não era um exemplo da beleza ano
do final do século passado
entendeu vou aprender a tocar violão e
cantar pra ver se melhora alguma coisa
aí comecei a tocar violão
chegou um momento que no final da
faculdade eu tocava fazer voz e violão à
noite eu estava fazendo um show de humor
eu estava estudando direito estudando
história até que no final do semestre
um aluna do curso de direito rúben
haroldo sabe que o atalho para a câmera
garoto sabe quem é que nunca vai advogar
na vida quem tu eu digo porque fulano
haroldo para advogar precisa ser todo
arrumadinho focado em um foco muito em
cima
mann é uma coisa que você usa que não
será um vocativo que serve tanto para o
homem quanto para mulher mãe é uma
abreviação de macho na jamaica também se
utiliza tem crise mã vel é muito
parecido
aplaudam
muito espontâneo é isso e eu acreditei
nisso que ela falou
ela falou inclusive haroldo advogado
precisa ser focado discreto calado não
pode fazer amizade fácil como faz cara
tem que ter uma camisa por dentro e
detalha o que ela falou na hora eu nem
me impressionei e tem que ser branquinho
hoje eu não a vai para essa pessoa
internas abiyei eu dou
acho pai é pai é outra palavra que vem
do e fim
deixa eu falar uma palavra cearense
palha não curto isso que ela falou não
concorda tem nada a ver não por isso não
pelo critério racial seria melhor
técnico seria melhor ou pior o advogado
um advogado mas acredita nisso falha
minha
eu acreditei nisso durante três ou
quatro anos da minha vida enfim eu
acredito que ela falou e eu mudei a
pessoa que eu era eu comecei a me
especializar em ser quem eu achava que a
humanidade queria e não obstante ter
duas pessoas na minha casa as mais
importantes da minha vida eu suponho que
as com respectivos pais e mães dos
senhores também sejam as mais
importantes pessoas mas não obstante o
que eles diziam que eu era muito
inteligente
dizem até hoje e que o super capaz eu
não acreditava comecei a escutar as
pessoas e aí a 64 anos de advocacia me
tornei uma pessoa ser com os pec está
trancada pra dentro
olá como vai tudo bem fazer pra que
fazer amizade fazer amizade não é legal
não vai me ajudar eu tenho que mostrar
distância para o cliente a advocacia não
acontecia
e quanto mais não acontecia o resultado
era outro
aí eu ficava ruim mesmo advocacia
compreendidos aí muita infelicidade tem
aqui é uma pessoa que faz muita coisa
mesmo tempo aqui ok eu faço muita coisa
mesmo tempo mas não sou eu e sim na foto
não sou eu é outra pessoa
eu acredito nisso entrei num processo de
pressão muito grande e profundo
tentei me matar algumas vezes eu tenho a
sorte de ter uma irmã psicóloga
maravilhosa que chegou aí na minha casa
em uma tarde como qualquer outro onde
estava cansado da minha vida
cansado de ser o projeto de fracasso
quando eu fiz a favelização 1ª 2ª 3ª 4ª
série houve sempre dos meus professores
você será um fracasso se não vai ser
nada na vida você não pára quieto
você não serve você não consegue fazer a
tarefa até o final
você não consegue fazer nada até o final
você não brilha
você não é inteligente você é burro eu
escutei isso a vida toda
incrivelmente isso não me afetou na
infância e na adolescência porque eu
tinha um país maravilhoso como de fato
eu ainda tenho mas saindo de casa
comecei a escutar isso é uma constante
na nossa vida à humanidade que ele dá
opinião eu vi um médico dizer que nós
quando você está entrando em um processo
de dividir suas dores com as outras
pessoas
você tem que primeiro ouvir do que dar
uma opinião isso é muito importante
enfim eu me lembro muito bem eu fui
posto para fora de sala por um professor
e ato contínuo foi suspenso pela
coordenação
a minha mãe ligou para o colégio e falou
com o professor professor fulano eu
tinha 13 anos de idade
aproveitei e fui pra extensão coisa que
vocês mais jovens não sabem o que é
extensa não sabe quem tá falando em casa
e tem outra pegar um negócio meio doida
muito difícil
fui lá para a extensão ouve a mãe dizer
o seguinte o meu filho é a criança mais
inteligente que existe nesse colégio
o meu filho é o mais capaz de todos mas
de fato ele tem um faniquito
tem um negócio que não consegue ficar
quieto eu não sei não me disse não eu
não tenho estudo
mas eu tenho certeza que alguma coisa
que pode atrapalhar ele como pode ajudar
minha mãe coitada a série ela falou isso
anos depois uma colega de faculdade onde
eu aciono nasceu no direito e essa
colega leciona na psiquiatria chegou pra
mim haroldo
vamos conversar vamos falar uma besteira
me mandou um psiquiatra psiquiatra
diagnóstico
eu sou portador ou tem uma condição de t
d h o que é o transtorno de déficit de
atenção e hiperatividade
pra falar a verdade eu sou tão pbh que
se você olhar no wikipédia vai ter um
momento que vai ter a minha foto lá do
lado do verbete do tdh eu não consigo
fazer uma coisa só
só se estiver apaixonado pelo tema
haroldo vamos dar uma aula sobre o novo
código de processo civil aplicada ao
processo trabalho mas eu vou vou fazer
um material zinho e começa a estudar se
apaixona pelo tema já era cinco dias
seguidos estudando 55 países
é assim que funciona comigo sempre
funcionou e para me dar bem eu precisei
conviver com isso
reconhecer que isso pode ser uma grande
vantagem e reconhecer que isso pode
também dificultar as coisas afinal
ninguém é super homem
e foi o que aconteceu a carreira
acadêmica e profissional muito difícil
muitas escolhas muitas dúvidas
eu tenho familiares absolutamente
inteligentes eu tenho uma tão
inteligente para ter um mundo só pra ela
ela padeceu entre aspas disso a franquia
eu tenho uma irmã tão maravilhosa que
pode tar música zoado palco cantando em
de casa busca a todo volume como é comum
na minha casa até hoje mesmo com meus
pais idosos mas ela conseguiu se
concentrar
eu tenho um irmão que tem uma memória
maravilhosa lembra de tudo e eu nunca
tive essas características de
concentração de memória
eu nunca tive as carteiras maravilhosos
que tornaram meus irmãos as pessoas
maravilhosas que são e eu comecei a
minha pequena e você começa a fingir
sabe eu me lembro é formado em direito e
do centro de convenções com o evento a
mãe não tinha nem onde
a mãe deixar no monza na moça
o monza quando chegava ele tinha cheiro
elite ao de todos os cintos sentidos ele
sabe o que fazer barulho ele tinha
cativo de óleo queimando ele treme o
chão todo mundo sabia que eu estava
chegando mãozinha
só vamos deixar só para deixar um
pouquinho antes se o governo é de menino
não é vergonha não pode me deixar na
frente eleita paulo momentos de tensão
chegando no centro de convenção até tá
bem essa mãe deles faça feliz nessa pai
por que o papai
ele não fala muito uma vez eu fui pro
retiro espiritual pai eu rezei para
caramba e voltei pra eu queria dizer uma
coisa que eu nunca disse que o seu
divino filho eu te amo pai eu te amo ele
pai eu quero ir por forró dos 3 amor foi
o pai com um amigo me buscar e deixar
nunca saí de casa pai deixou ir por
favor o papai nem pagar
ele gosta de mim todo mundo gosta de mim
não sei que dez minutos depois da peça
manhã treinos ele começou a explorar
lá o meu único paletó a pasta que eu
tinha ganho vendendo os ingressos do
evento além do governador do estado
ali o prefeito de fortaleza ali a menina
que paquerava software asseada a 0 e
agora vai eu andando lá até que
determinado momento anda não acho que
eles foram embora
estou vendo mais o carro aí eu escuto
filho eu digo não não é o que está
acontecendo diz pra mim deus que não é a
mãe gritando deus faz um milagre não é a
mãe
aí eu digo não se eu continuar andando
vai dar tudo certo nada acontece
eu entro aqui estava chegando perto da
porta de vidro quando eu entrei haroldo
filho seu marido vivido nesse momento o
governador o prefeito o presidente da
oab a minha paquera aquele cara chato da
faculdade chegou comigo sabiam que eu
era o haroldo filho não duvido advogados
e eu fingi que estava bem advogado
ganhar dinheiro
quando eu me virei me virei triste que
foi mais do que há cinco reais
eu fingi que estava bem na advocacia
montanhas que torna difícil no seu nome
pega pega lá no centro
chega um cliente finalmente chega uma
pessoa provavelmente bem vestidos e
shorts morreu né
chegava lá tudo bem eu fingi na hora que
estava no telefone finge não não todo
juiz gosta de mim hoje
não eu sou um dos melhores advogados da
nova geração
não não todos me temem hoje e eu
desliguei quando o cara fala de tudo bom
tudo bom é que o wand é consertar seu
telefone
gente eu vou resumindo triste infeliz
pobre
resolvi voltar a ser quem era fazer tudo
que eu me sinto capaz de fazer o que eu
gosto de fazer
hoje me tornei advogado professor de
direito
blogger eu faço alguns documentos de
política história eu sou cantou eu sou
ator comediante muita gente me conhece e
um coisa está ajudando a outra
no final das contas eu lembro do que a
mãe lhe falou e do que meu pai me falou
isso eu coloco dentro do meu coração
todos os dias e não me importo de ser
chamado de palhaço o que é ser palhaço é
a coisa mais linda que o ser humano pode
fazer
iremos nos nos exemplos das crianças e
para aquelas pessoas que têm ph eu ainda
vou ficar aqui porque não tem um minuto
enfim aquelas pessoas que têm perder h
eu só tenho um recado aqui é um livro
novo chamado bíblia
tudo tem o seu tempo determinado e há
tempo para todo propósito debaixo do céu
só tem uma boa noite muito obrigado